there's no one-size-fits-all approach to
education and that parents are in the
best position to make the right choices
for their own children
hi I'm Nicolas we with reason TV and
today we're talking with Melanie
hildreth she's a director of development
at the Institute for justice and we're
talking about in a fascinating case
about school choice in Nevada
Melanie thanks for joining us thank you
very much talk a bit about the law that
was passed that is arguably the most
comprehensive school choice semi voucher
program in the country what does it do
and when does it go into effect this
year Nevada passed the most innovative
and expansive school choice program in
the country it effects every student in
Nevada Public Schools that's 450,000
kids and what the state did is create
education savings accounts this gives
parents the ability to customize their
children's education by spending their
educational dollars on a variety of
educational goods and services and they
can basically use it for whatever they
want I mean that's the idea and it it
comes out of tax dollars it's what five
thousand dollars about five thousand
dollars per student and and then they
get a card or a bank account that they
can say okay I'm gonna use it to pay
tuition here or extra extra tutoring
here or you know a computer or hardware
for here exactly yeah they can spend it
on tuition at a private school but it
doesn't have to be tuition at a private
school which makes it different from a
voucher it can be spent on tutoring
textbooks distance learning even classes
at Nevada Community College's this is
for everybody in K through 12 yes and
what happens with money that is not
spent they can save it and I I think in
some states I actually don't know if
this is for Nevada but in some states
they can even apply it to call it so who
could be against this well two lawsuits
have been filed challenging the program
one by the ACLU and one by a group
called educate Nevada now there are two
basic cases that they're making against
that one is that this actually erodes a
wall of separation between church and
state because the money can be used at
private religious schools that's that's
right the ACLU of Nevada has argued that
it violates the program violates the
Nevada Constitution because parents can
choose religious schools as one of the
options and why isn't that true as IJ
has successfully argued
for the US Supreme Court and several
state Supreme Court's properly
constructed school choice programs do
not unconstitutionally fund religion and
we worked actually with the Nevada
Legislature to ensure that this was
properly constructed so the program
meets the two hallmarks of a properly
constructed program because it relies on
the free and independent choice of
parents among an array of options both
religious and non-religious so it's not
it's not privileged in religious schools
over anything else furthering a
particular religion exactly exactly in
the state itself is completely neutral
with regard to religion it is in favor
to see the parents or the kids could by
say maybe you know Gatorade for a sports
program but they can't by holding water
it's for non-sectarian like you know
they're not doing it to get religion
they're doing it to get education the
the funds are for the child's education
and if the benefit is to the family and
to the child and not to the religious
institution so the other main legal case
against us are legal challenges that
this undermines Nevada's constitutional
mandate to provide a uniform and
consistent free public education how do
you rip out that in the IJ case this
program really doesn't do anything to
change or undermine Nevada's obligation
to fund and operate the public schools
all that it does is recognize that
there's no one-size-fits-all approach to
education and that parents are in the
best position to make the right choices
for their own children why would no
school you know let's say I and I'm not
sure the exact numbers in Nevada but if
the typical school spends nine thousand
dollars on a kid and then five thousand
goes you know with the kid who leaves
they're still left with four thousand
dollars but isn't that and they don't
have to do anything for it isn't that
like a win-win for them yeah you think
so it just it is a challenge to the
status quo because it really gives the
power to parents and that is right talk
a little bit about you know one of the
families that you're representing
because there's a total of is it six or
seven plaintiffs we're representing five
Nevada families whose children have a
wide variety of needs when it comes to
education one family is
Amy and Heath hare who have five adopted
children and their oldest son was
bullied in his public school and they
were concerned for his safety so this
program makes it possible for them to
put him in a school where they feel that
he's safe and to do the same for all of
their kids which would be
cost-prohibitive and if they have to
destroy the great tradition of public
school in America you know it's all
about them right that's it's their
choice what what's another family
we are also representing Aurora Espinoza
who's a single mother with two daughters
who are trapped by their zip code in
some of the worst public schools in
Nevada one of the families we represent
has children with serious health
problems medical problems that require
them to be away from school for
surgeries and and other you know really
difficult circumstances and with this
program their parents can tailor their
education to accommodate their needs in
a way that is completely impossible in
their current situation what is public
opinion in Nevada I mean obviously this
law was passed by the state legislature
so it has a certain amount of support is
there a sense that people in Nevada are
you know are they outraged are they like
you're draining money from the public
school system with this program or they
like Jesus huh you know where do I sign
up for that there's been a lot of
enthusiasm about the program but because
it's new there's also some people people
have some reservations so it were really
excited for it to go into effect and
have the people get to see the result
once they have the opportunity to make
these choices I think people will be
very excited about the program across
the board it has the potential to bring
the kind of innovation to education and
Nevada that we've seen modern technology
bring to everything from the
transportation to the retail sector if
there's anything that businesses like
uber and Amazon have shown us it's that
people value choices it may value
options and this program gives parents
choices and options and one of the most
important areas of their life which is
the education of their children and I
think that that's something that people
will really respond to well once they
see it in effect we've been talking with
Melanie Hildreth she works at the
Institute for justice libertarian public
interest law firm thanks so much for
talking to us
thank you for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie